[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
a hell of a morning
[Music]
sorry to relate to the air I've been
listening to uh this James absolutely
neutering Donald Trump his family his
business and his business associates the
grime family that is the the Trump grind
family is in big trouble here in the
state of New York welcome welcome to the
Tony Michaels podcast we have a uh we
have we have a new scenery for you here
look at this
um this James comes out this morning uh
in a press conference it was supposed to
happen over an hour ago it just it just
started just under 30 minutes ago
um she has laid out several crimes
several crimes that uh Donald Trump and
his family and his organization has
committed
um over the years most of them have to
do with uh real estate and uh money
laundering it seems but more defrauding
the state of New York out of tax dollars
um she is answering questions right now
it looks like her team is going to
continue to answer questions and she not
just she didn't just lay out the lawsuit
that she's bringing against Trump and
the Trump crime family and also his
business associates at the Trump
organization
but this is uh this is big news because
uh
it no it is a civil lawsuit you have to
remember that it is a civil lawsuit but
it does bar not just Donald Trump but
also his his family members like Donald
Trump Jr and Ivanka from actually
participating in any kind of real estate
deal
um and and barring them from even
sitting on the board
um of any kind of New York Corporation
now this is the state of New York
so remember that this is within the
confines of the borders of the state of
New York
that's where this is
um this is not this is not a situation
where
um this is going to be federal law so
this is why Trump moved to Florida in
the first place right this is why he
moved the floor this is why he continued
to you know absolutely
um you know try to skate the law here
but he's not going to escape Tish James
and the other thing that we know now I
guess is that
um the The Jig was up with Donald Trump
Jr and Ivanka uh she did say that Alan
weisselberg and Donald Trump pled to
fifth
um so but let's do this let's go to the
press conference here
um with tis James see if I can unmute
this and let's listen to a little bit of
the other press conference and illegal
and as a result of that we are seeking
relief and he and Mr Trump the Trump
organization his family they should all
be held accountable and that is the
purpose of this litigation that we are
filing today in addition to referring
the criminal conduct to the southern
district of New York as well as the IRS
no one my friend is above the law
attorney general I wonder I have two
part question number one
um is there anything to prevent Mr Trump
from establishing his corporations even
for the properties in New York in
another state since he has now become a
legal resident of Florida and secondly
you called it Donald Trump Jr has
already started tweeting that this quote
the Democratic Witch Hunt has begun if
you'd like to respond to that as well so
with regards to the name calling as you
know
um they've uh basically have attempted
to delay
this investigation and to Federate two
judges have dismissed those claims that
this was a political Witch Hunt so I
give no Credence to those
names that he referred he's referred to
me
um and two
um he's Mr Trump the Trump organization
as well as his family will still have to
deal with this complaint they will still
have to respond they will still have to
respond to the allegations they're in
and so it if in fact he decided to move
to Florida the reality is he still has
to deal with the great state of New York
and respond to the complaint
properties in the corporation
New York some are Incorporated in
Delaware but they do business in the
state of New York and he cannot just
pick up and those same corporations can
be moved to Florida no
and and again Marcia just to put a finer
point on that we are attempting as part
of our relief to dissolve these
corporations
uh
biggest money generating properties are
in Manhattan in New York state
um would he uh if this if this relief is
granted by the judge down the road would
he be able to collect rents to obtain
loans on the properties uh what what
percent you know what what practical
um implications to sell the properties
should he wants is the corporation
that's filed in New York necessary for
him to do those things so again all most
of the corporations are have been
Incorporated in the state of New York
there are some have that been
Incorporated in Delaware but they
continue to do business in the state of
New York we are again our permanently
barring Mr Trump and his family members
from serving as an officer or director
in any entity in the state of New York
we are borrowing him from entering into
any commercial real estate transactions
for five years we are barring Mr Trump
and the organization from applying for
any loans for five years just for five
years requiring him to repay the
financial benefits of 250 million
dollars placing a monitor over these
corporations appointing requiring him to
file a gap compliant
um uh Financial State a statement of
financial condition replacing the
trustees
um uh if in fact he creates a new
trustee and permanently barring Alan
weisselberg and Jeffrey mcconney and
canceling his certificate of
incorporations for those corporations
that we discussed yes
are these relief that a judge would have
to approve yes
so these things aren't happening at the
moment correct this is what will be
litigated now correct and it's important
also to understand that Mr Trump will
continue to have a financial interest in
a lot of these corporations
um and so if he decides to at some point
in time sell them or if he decides to
restructure them again this is all part
of the belief that we are seeking I said
to Marcia that we're seeking to dissolve
them that was incorrect we're not
seeking to dissolve dissolve them he
still has a financial interest in these
businesses and Corporation
owns that correct however to collect
rent to obtain alone uh based on them as
collateral to
um sell the property uh maybe I'm
missing some other practical things if
if approved by a judge down the road
these are things he would not be able to
do with those problems correct for the
next five years
question
uh Josh gerstein with Politico yeah
Madam attorney general can you explain
something about how the former president
you alleged he did this for at least a
decade or more than a decade
um how did he get away with what you're
saying he got away with for such a long
period of time a lot of these
transactions are with some of the
largest financial institutions and
insurance companies in the state of New
York do they just not check anything
that people tell them or they presumed
it was true or did they have hints that
these things were not true that they
were being told and what does it tell
you about those institutions that they
would take his word for it so let me
just say with respect to mazar's mazars
mizores indicated on the statement of
financial condition that it did not
certify and they did not audit these
statements that does not absolve Mr
Trump of submitting accurate information
to with respect to Cushman Wakefield
there is an ongoing investigation into
Cushman Wakefield and then lastly with
respect to Deutsche Bank Deutsche Bank
we're in conversations with Deutsche
Bank they have been cooperating with our
office
do you feel like this lawsuit is going
to be resolved quickly or do you feel
like this is going to be a drawn out
process so that's entirely up to the
judge
that's good okay
[Music]
I thank you all for coming and if
there's any specific questions I believe
my members of the team will answer your
questions thank you
so there you have it
um looks like the press conference is
going to be coming to an end here
and we will have um just James
um going to
um
suing the Trump org and its members uh
the Trump family it looks like um Trump
is absolutely [ __ ] fact fact [ __ ]
here
um so there's a couple different things
and people are talking about this in the
chat number one uh they're they're
asking about over valuing properties so
here's the scheme that tis James has
laid out it looks like Trump was uh part
of what he would do is he would
undervalue the properties when they had
to pay property tax he would overvalue
the properties when he went to get loans
from Banks which is fraud
um so undervaluing the property for
taxes fraud and actually overvaluing the
property to get bank loans is fraud
that's where she's actually going to
give the criminal referral it seems to
the IRS and the Department of Justice at
the sdny
and the reason why is because the fraud
against the state in New York is the one
where he would um undervalue properties
to skate paying more property tax the
federal uh fraud here is where Donald
Trump would uh overvalue properties to
receive bank loans so they're fraudulent
bank loans which uh the banks and bank
loans and Bank applications that's all
done under the gas of the federal
government and the Department of Justice
and also the IRS probably has to do with
the taxes
um the federal taxes that he paid so
they have evidence not only that he he
defrauded the state of New York and the
citizens of New York with his
corporations and through his deals he
also was defrauding the federal
government
um that's what the suggestion would be
where uh
tis James is actually referring these
cases as criminal cases to the IRS and
the sdny
we know that the Trump organizations is
already under criminal indictment in the
state of New York
for fraud and the Manhattan DA's office
uh as is Alan weisselberg who has pled
guilty who is apparently cooperating now
now this is this is the important part
here is that that trial that trial is
going to be
um had very soon uh I think Gabe is in
the comments here he says these are all
allegations
that's your best argument fake game I
love it I love that that's your best
argument buddy I I actually like that
you're here that you that you give voice
to stupidity um that way we can you know
set that stupidity ball up on the T and
knock it out of the park because these
are all allegations but Gabe the problem
that you have with the allegations is
that there's criminal charges on Alan
weisselberg and the Trump organization
and Alan weisselberg has has pled guilty
to the charges that have also been
brought against the Trump organization
criminally inside the Manhattan DA's
office which is going to be tried here
very soon and Alan weiselberg is going
to be a witness
against the Trump organization and we
see that in his plea deal and the judge
made that very clear in his plea deal
the other thing the other thing that I
think is funny about the allegations is
that now now that now that it's going to
go to court of course it's going to be a
big Mayhem it's going to be a bunch of
chaos this isn't going to happen
tomorrow they're not going to dissolve
the Trump organization tomorrow but
think about the timing of this
the Trump organization and his ability
to actually
um launder money in the state of New
York is very important and Tish James
laid this out it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if these corporations
live in Delaware Dad she doesn't give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] she doesn't care if these
organizations and these businesses they
live incorporate in Delaware they do
business in New York that is the most
important thing is that Tish James as
the attorney general has the
jurisdiction of her borders of New York
and it doesn't matter that this business
is Incorporated in Delaware that doesn't
that doesn't now she can't do anything
about the crimes that they commit in
Delaware she's the New York attorney
general but what she can do is she can
go after the corporations that are
Incorporated in the state in New York
and also she can go out to the
corporations that do business in New
York that is the most important thing
here that is is the most important thing
so it's going to be very hard for Trump
to unwind all this my guess is that
we're going to watch the Trump family
the Trump org and Trump himself start to
liquidate a lot of these properties and
she even kind of went over that with the
questions from some of the reporters
and why that's significant is because
he's going to need some liquid cash
probably
to pay back this 250 million dollars if
if the court sees it fit
so
um again he's not in good shape here
with this civil lawsuit the other thing
that is important to know about this
civil lawsuit as opposed to a criminal
lawsuit because everyone wants to watch
the perp walk you how much satisfaction
did you get at a watching Steve Bannon B
burp walked handcuffed behind his back
whining him bitching about how he's the
victim oh my God so [ __ ] beautiful
what a great day that was for America
and what a great day it'll be for
America When Donald Trump is finally
perp walked and Gabe is pointing this
out fake Gabe here he's pointing us out
at civil but they gave I don't think you
quite understand how how
how important that is
that this is worse for Trump being civil
than criminal
and here's why
Trump relies on the Trump Organization
for his income for him to appear to be
rich because Trump is not as rich as he
says if you believe anything Trump says
you're [ __ ] out of your mind you're
out of your [ __ ] mind if you believe
anything this this slob has to say now
the most important part about it being
Civil Fate Gabe
any allegations
you do know that the the bar the bar
is much lower when it comes to civil
crime well civil suits I should say when
you have a civil lawsuit the bar of
guilt is much much much lower we see
that in the Alex Jones civil suits
that the victims of Sandy Hook have
brought against him the bar is very low
in a civil suit and the 250 million
dollars it doesn't feel like a lot but
really honestly the amount of money that
Trump doesn't have is gonna really get
hurt bad with 250 million dollars this
guy has said you know he's probably just
hemorrhaging money
that's all he does is hemorrhage money
it's always the next scheme to pay for
the last scheme we know this guy's been
a grifter we know this guy's been a con
man his entire [ __ ] life everything
to this guy is a con
and Gabe I'm glad you pointed this out
because yes it is a civil lawsuit
the most detrimental thing to Donald
Trump here
is that the bar for Guilt in the civil
lawsuit is a hell of a lot lower a hell
of a lot lower the burden to prove it's
a hell a lot lower and I don't know if
you were listening to the press
conference and I'm sure you weren't I'm
sure you won't go listen to the press
conference because it's your orange
Mussolini Jesus and there's no way you
will listen to anything that goes
against
um you know the truth in your orange
Mussolini Jesus
laughs
but here's the thing is that this
lawsuit that tits James is bringing is
gonna cut the Trump organization down
like a fresh cut tree this is why Donald
Trump Jr has been freaking the [ __ ] out
on his videos this is why he looks this
is why Donald Trump Jr looks like [ __ ] I
don't know if you've seen his videos
lately but he looks like he's lost 35
pounds and not a good 35 pounds a really
bad 35 pounds of guy he hasn't eaten
he's probably got a a an exclusive diet
of of cocaine and booze
um they're [ __ ] here this is not good
for the Trump organization this is not
good for Trump this is not good for
Trump the Trump family they are really
completely [ __ ] here with this civil
lawsuit because not only is the civil
lawsuit gonna hurt them
um in the long run because it's not
going to happen tomorrow
um it's going to hurt them in the long
run but it's going to hurt him at a time
where it's possible that these people
are indicted on crimes and they're
sitting in federal courtrooms uh
indicted on federal crimes which is
important even in this case because
they're making criminal referrals to the
Department of Justice through the sdny
and the IRS I don't know if you're
listening to that part that's very
[ __ ] important
this guy's [ __ ] Capital f-u-c-k [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] but you know what [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them we've had enough of this [ __ ]
and you know he was tweeting earlier
about Putin and tweeting not tweeting he
was he was posting on fraud social and
whatever the hell the truthing is that
what they call it of Jesus Christ
um he was posting about uh Putin earlier
he says President Putin of Russia is now
threatening the use of nuclear weapons
saying it's not a bluff the Ukrainian
conflict should never have happened
and would not have happened if I were
president
but as I have made clear for quite some
time this could now end up being World
War III
um
so he is essentially threatening world
war three siding with Putin here again
you know not surprising this is what got
him in this situation in the first place
not only with tis James this morning but
his criminal
his criminal liability in Florida his
criminal liability in DC with a grand
jury that's looking into the January 6
Insurrection and the overturning of our
election and the fraudulent uh slate of
electors
but here's the thing
if he wouldn't have been a Putin
sycophant and wouldn't have really
went all in on Putin because he really
wanted that Tower in Moscow or wherever
the [ __ ] it was in Russia that he wanted
a tower you know I don't know else what
else P tape and stuff that was held over
his head but if he would have came down
the escalator
and said I want to run but I'm not going
to none of this would be happening none
of this would be happening Trump or his
organization or or his family
that's for damn sure none of it would
have happened
um we would we would be talking about
the the next season of The Apprentice
and how Donald Trump's tweeting out
racist [ __ ] today
he would not have been president of the
United States
and if he wouldn't have been you know
Putin's little puppet and I believe
that's what the documents are honestly I
mean you know that's all speculation on
my part but here's the thing
here's the thing
why would Trump take documents and call
them his documents if they didn't have
his name on them why what what what
they they have his name on him folks
those documents that they're arguing
about in court of over special Master
which is a whole nother [ __ ] story
here
I know a whole nother judge story Trump
[ __ ] up over calculation miscalculation
whatever the hell you want to call it
here
these documents have his [ __ ] name on
them
they have his name on him it's the
intelligence that was gathered about him
in Russia
and the collusion and the way that he
was trying to steal away our elections
that's what it's about
that's what it'll continue to be about
those documents that's why he's so
scared of the government
exposing what those documents are and he
only did us a favor
this guy always does us a favor and I
know it feels like oh my God just lock
him up already but really honestly
why why would you lock up someone at
this point who is absolutely just
admitting the crime I'm sure today he
will go on his fraud social media
account
he's gonna go over there to front social
and he's gonna absolutely admit to the
crimes that this James is laid out in
this press conference Hondo persento
I would almost bet that is exactly what
he's going to do
he's going to start posting about
admitting the crime that he's committed
on fraud social
that test James laid out today
it's probably what's going to happen
and he's probably going to do some kind
of Nazi rally where he does a q Anon
seance
where they they salute the the fear her
that that the Trump dumpster fire
and and he's going to call for more
violence
because he really honestly World War III
and more violence is
this guy's only way out that's why he
called on these people to come to
Washington come January 6. it'll be wild
It's Gonna Be Wild
we're gonna we're gonna take over the
government I'm gonna become dictator
it's gonna be wild it's gonna be crazy
that was always that was always the
[ __ ] Ploy here
and for anyone anyone to still be in
this guy's Camp I mean anyone
not just not just the Trump sick events
I'm talking about
I'm talking about even low level people
who he wouldn't give a [ __ ] about if he
met them on the street
like like fake Gabe over there he
wouldn't give two shits about fake game
he wouldn't give fake gave four [ __ ]
seconds of thought
he would probably he would probably
think that fake game is gross
he he doesn't like you fake Gabe that's
what I'm trying to say that's what I'm
trying to say
oh
he's in big [ __ ] trouble folks not
just criminally but civilly he's really
[ __ ] up here he really [ __ ] up when
he ran for prison he really did he
brought this all on himself
he brought this all on himself that's
what this is that's what it's going to
continue to be we're going to uh surf
the Tweety tweets and Trinity Trends
today but I got a couple nonsense I want
to make
uh don't forget
to go over to Tony Michaels dot live we
are still on a YouTube band
we're trying on we're trying really hard
to get it turned off but it's not we're
not having any success they hate that
[ __ ] video that I made they [ __ ]
hate it which you know whatever I I what
am I gonna do
what am I gonna do it's their platform
they can turn me off if they want that's
why once you go to Tony Michaels dot
Live support Independent Media there
there's a little box
there's a little box okay it's it looks
kind of like this right here on the
screen there's a little box there on
tonymichaels.live where you can support
Independent Media you can either give a
one-time tip or you can tip us each
month where it does it automatically
five dollars ten dollars twenty hundred
whatever you want to give now if you
can't give money to support Independent
Media I want you to support it in all
sorts of ways there's all sorts of ways
you can support Independent Media like
the Tony Michaels podcast again we're
not on YouTube right now but what I want
you to do is I want you to go over to
YouTube and I know it sounds weird but I
want you to go subscribe to YouTube if
you aren't subscribed to our Channel on
YouTube already get your ass over there
and go subscribe because it's very
important that we pile up as many Subs
as we can that is one thing that YouTube
has said as we have tried and tried and
tried again with more appeals is they
said well your accounts you know usually
bigger accounts
um get some sort of uh appeal past the
original appeal like don't listen to a
bigger account so the bigger we are the
more subs we have the more views we have
the better off we are and really
honestly why wouldn't you want to come
listen to us every single weekday over
on YouTube or anywhere
every single weekday we use two hours a
day and really honestly we want to go to
three hours and we're gonna bring on
sponsors here really soon we're working
on getting sponsors
um and our viewership is up thank you so
much I can't believe how much support
you guys have given over the last week
through this band it has been so
reassuring it has given us more fire to
keep going to not stop because you guys
just because our YouTube account got
shut down didn't mean you guys did not
stop listening frankly you guys you guys
participated and engaged more
with our show and our content in the
last week and it is uh I I want to tell
you I appreciate all of that I
appreciate you being here I appreciate
you engaging on Facebook speaking of
Facebook go follow our page on Facebook
just go to the Tony Michaels or type in
the Tony Michaels podcast you can follow
our page on Facebook or just go to
tonymichaels.live
you can click the little sandwich icon
at the top it'll give you a place where
you can go to all the links all the
links where you can follow us just click
on that it takes you to the link tree
and the link tree will give you all the
links that you have to follow us on
Twitch you can follow us on Twitch which
is another great place to watch because
the chat over there has been Lively
since YouTube's been shut down you can
also download us every single weekday
on Apple Spotify Google anywhere you get
your podcast you can listen to the
podcast and boy have you guys been
listening to it there's been a record
number of downloads this week
just because you know I I want to
believe that it's because of YouTube man
but I think you guys just said you know
enough of that enough of that stuff
let's have pro-democracy speech Let's
Get pro-democracy speech some support
so support Independent Media wherever
you can and it doesn't just mean giving
money now if you want to do that you can
right here there's a box at
tonymichaels.live where you can give a
tip a one-time tip or you can do a
monthly tip where it does it
automatically every month without you
having to think about it
and everything is much much and greatly
appreciated but here's the thing you
don't have to just give money to support
independent media share it with your
family your friends
email the link send the link share it on
Facebook uh you know you can retweet it
you can tweet about the show you can you
can share the podcast every single week
on Apple Spotify Google you can share
the podcast every single week with your
family
with your friends with your community
members because we have to lean into
democracy here folks we can't just let
tissue we can't rely on tis James and
Department of Justice to save our
democracy it's up to us
we save it by doing democracy which is
leaning into it using the power of the
ballot to smash these fascists once and
for all
to get rid of these frauds these phonies
these threats to our country and our way
of life that's what they are so go to
Tony
michaels.livesupport independent support
Independent Media there
stay tuned don't go anywhere we got done
we're gonna round up the Tweety tweets
and Trinity Trends Gabe Sanchez is going
to join us in just a few minutes don't
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after these messages stick around we'll
be right back
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around through the break
[Music]
holy moly kiss James absolutely neuters
Donald Trump the Trump organization and
the Trump family
and his and his criminal friends his
gang of criminal friends as well holy
[ __ ] absolutely neuters him
when I was a kid I grew up on a farm and
we would castrate
and a steer
Bulls so you would you would castrate
them and it's a it's a really oh man
it's a really
it's a really brutal process
you gotta get him in a shoot you gotta
kind of lock their head in
and the reason why you would steer a
bull a calf a bull calf is to get them
ready to feed them out for beef that's
what you would do that's how you would
beef them up as they say
and you'd feed them out to get them nice
and fat before you you know grow them
before you would butcher them you know
you want to have a nice
a nice crop when you go butcher a calf
all right our steer
really gross bloody process and it
reminds he so much it reminds me so much
of what Tish James did today just
absolutely absolutely
with a sharp [ __ ] knife
castry neuter
steer Donald Trump his organization his
family and his criminal allies
it is uh it is something a sight to be
seen
today is a good day in America now again
as test James laid out with some of the
questions afterwards
um this doesn't mean that this is
effective immediately this has to go
through the court she has filed a civil
lawsuit against Trump his business
and his family
and his his criminal allies in his
business Alan weisselberg some other
folks that helped run his business
but it is the beginning of the end of
the Trump organization
um
I think now she's been barred
him and his family and his in his
criminal allies in his business from
um actually incorporating any businesses
or being on the board or participating
as officers of any of these businesses
um and she also laid out with the
reporters with their questions it's
really going to affect
um even even if he tries to reorganize
or he tries to hide stuff I mean they
know they already know all this they
know where it's at they know what he did
it's not it's not a [ __ ] secret
anymore
he really is [ __ ] here
he really is completely [ __ ]
um
I want to bring on
our co-host Gabe Sanchez here see what
his his take on it here is here this is
incredible Gabe what do you think he's
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] he's completely
[ __ ] completely
he I mean it's coming out with the Civil
fraud lawsuit and then saying you know
oh yeah we're going after you for 250
million dollars for defrauding lenders
like there's no easy way to do it she's
Banning them from New York from doing
business uh I mean no banking
institution will want to touch him and I
mean well not not at this point oh yeah
they have a they're gonna they're gonna
seek a five-year
um ban on them
um uh at all and it doesn't matter you
know she even kind of laid out about
Delaware
um corporations and businesses that he
has incorporated in Delaware because
again I want everyone to understand this
is a civil lawsuit which the bar is
lower than a criminal than a criminal
charge but also she is within the
confines of the borders of the state in
New York yeah so she can't actually go
after the incorporation of a Delaware
business but she can go after the
business that a Delaware Corporation
does inside the state of New York
um so that is what is most important
because a lot of people think oh well
he's so smart he's Incorporated these
businesses in other states and it
prevents him from being charged civilly
no that's all [ __ ] now if he
if he had a Delaware Corporation and he
did not did not do business inside New
York it would be out of her jurisdiction
it would be out of her purview to bring
civil or criminal charges against those
businesses but that is not as what
happened here right I mean here's the
thing it's like you know uh New York
Georgia
obviously what's going on with the
Mar-A-Lago documents like there's you
know no simple way to put it other than
he is [ __ ] right you've got a guy who
is committing crimes who thought that he
was you know the Teflon Don and after a
while the Teflon wears off a pan right
and you begin to see the uh the
consequences is my mic better now is my
mic better now yeah yeah much better
well I I sounded like you were I know
that you rearranged the room wow yeah so
every your ex kind of echoing yeah so
everyone everyone uh can see here that
I'm in a different setting I'm actually
in the same room I just I got a bigger
disc so I had to turn my desk a bit and
so it must have in the setup of that I
must have lost
um where my mic was but you can hear me
now this is much better it's perfect
this is back to how it was oh so this is
like original Tony Michaels podcast
volume style yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
okay whatever everyone's saying the
sound is much better yeah I had the
wrong microphone on because I got a
couple different mics here oh it happens
it's Fancy no no no well I mean I have
the standard mic on my computer right
and I that's the one that was sucking
the sound through and then I have the
one that's in front of me which now you
notice it's it's down low it's not yeah
it's not hanging down low you know yeah
right well you know here's the thing if
you look at my setup here I wanted
everyone to see the TV yeah and so if I
had the microphone hanging you can't
really
can't really see it if you can't really
see it now the thing is is I'm actually
playing uh Pluto TV in the background
because it's free and I'm cheap some
[ __ ] so yeah who else is a cheap son of
a [ __ ] who's that Trump oh really
really so what else what else stuck out
to you because I was trying to listen to
this and create the stream so there's a
few things that I missed on these cases
because she was really laying out like
like she's like look this I'm not just
bringing a lawsuit for no [ __ ] reason
here's the reason boom boom boom boom
here's a couple of [ __ ] examples of
how this game was committing crime well
she's got over 200 I think it's 222
Pages it's definitely over 200 pages I
mean which means in in this in this memo
that she's releasing right it's a 200
Page lawsuit that's right uh you know
alleging the fraud that touches all
aspects of the Trump business including
the properties and golf courses
slash the cemetery uh you know but it is
one of the well that's in Florida but it
is one of those things that uh
uh she brought the receipts this isn't
one of those like hey here's a 14-page
document for a lawsuit that says like
what are the crimes like this is years
of work years of her team and others
coming together I mean I think she
quoted Michael Cohen in there he was a
he you know and he's he we had him on
the show uh a week and a half ago right
yeah yeah yeah I think it was last last
week last week uh I mean time flies but
like even he said he's like look I gave
them all this stuff right I was the
first one to come forward and you know
she is out there quoting to be like we
couldn't have started this or done this
without Michael Cohen's help because he
was kind of the Catalyst that got things
started and so because of him we're able
to go forward and actually follow
through with the lawsuit like this a 200
Page lawsuit that is not
that's that's a that's not that's like
nothing to [ __ ] like uh uh kind of
like dismiss at all that is something
that again
has the receipts this is from different
people organizations other contractors
vendors whoever might be
these people are coming back to prove
that they have misled in the evaluation
by inflating the property value uh
through appraisals uh um you know and
then obviously uh referring them to the
IRS not just Trump but his adult
children as he's as they've quoted uh in
different Publications because they are
also part of the Trump organization
which means they they cannot just say oh
we we didn't know what happened like
they did with weiselberg right this is
one of those things that all of these
people had insight and have more info on
I mean remember uh weiselberg said I've
count how many ever hundred of times
that he said I plead the fifth you have
Eric Trump who said over 500 times he
pleads the fifth this is not a group of
people that are acting in the best
interest of helping this investigation
they're trying to prevent right from
digging in well without their help
they've been able to do so but uh it's
since since Alan Weisberg pled the fifth
he actually pled guilty in in the
criminal case against him in this in the
Manhattan DA's office which is under the
the uh direction of the state of New
York everyone knows the Manhattan dies
estate uh prosecutor they bring it in
state court and um he also having said
that Alan weisselberg has also been
instructed by the judges you will
cooperate against a trump organization
here that is something that you are
going to do
um and if you do not you're in big
trouble so um because he basically the
judge let Alan weisenberg off light and
I'm here the other thing too is is that
and maybe we should reach out to going
to see if he wants to come on in the
next couple weeks to talk about this
um but uh you know Michael Cohen has
said time and time and time again
um he's been yelling it from the
rooftops that hey I I I gave them
everything they needed and I think this
is the other thing that is most
important
in this entire press conference is that
she is gonna give a criminal referral to
not only not only the IRS but also the
sdny which we know Michael Cohen was
cooperating there as well because that's
where the charges were brought against
him an individual one
um and he even said in that interview
last week that he lays out in his new
book The reason why is they threatened
uh his family for with charges because
the way that they were that Donald Trump
was repaying him for the money that he
paid out to Stormy Daniels
um they were doing it through uh Michael
Cohen's wife and that and that is how
they were going to draw in his wife and
the last thing that Trump wanted was
some of these charges that were they
were going to charge
um Michael Cohen with and the reason why
is because individual one would also be
guilty of those judges which we now know
that I mean we've always known that it
was Trump I mean it was Trump I mean
water is wet right right well right it's
kind of obvious but the other thing so
there is something I want to point out
so a statement was given out by Trump's
attorney uh Elena Haba the racist woman
already already wait wait is this a is
this a shitty legal take because I have
to say she's got some shitty ones is
this a shitty one or is this by the way
did you tell people what happened to our
video on YouTube
which one the one that got flagged
buying Newsmax was it Newsmax right oh
yeah yeah so we did a we we did these
shitty legal takes with Haba and um I I
think it was one it was from Newsmax
right yeah yeah so we took a clip from
Newsmax and what we do is you you put
the intro on the front the little the
little uh early 90s uh sitcom intro and
with the shitty legal takes words on it
the logo and then it's just we just play
the clip with the laugh track over we
don't edit the clip in any way I mean
other than it's cut but you know end to
end but it's just a laugh track when she
says really stupid [ __ ] or the host says
really stupid [ __ ]
Newsmax hit us with a copyright claim on
that video I'm not and it was it's like
a I don't know it's like a 45 second
clip of her giving really shady oh where
the radio was to actually go they did
not like that we put that laugh track
over top of their clip they did not like
that so Newsmax now we don't we actually
don't monitor ties those I don't think
um well I mean we now we can't because
they have copyright claim over I mean we
can keep it on our Channel they can't
prevent us from you know using it as
satire but they can they can do a
copyright
that's out I mean like and it really
goes to show you and I'll quickly go
back to what you were saying but it
really goes to show you that this is a
similar behavior that everyone does on
the right uh a right wing Media or
right-wing pundits or just people on the
right right Maga they want to say that
people on the left or anyone who is
anti-maga are snowflakes but when the
tables are turned and they're on the
receiving end of the joke they are the
butt of the joke they get they get very
upset they get very sensitive and they
go hey that's not fair it's like when
you know Biden called them out for being
semi-fascist right and oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa that's that's that's not fair you
can't do that right after which they
have obviously been so vile and
disgusting and and denigrating to other
people it's when they're called fashion
or when they're called bullies they get
very upset but back to what Alina Haba
had mentioned today in a statement she
wrote to CNN
today's filing is neither focused on the
facts nor the law okay rather it is
solely focused on advancing the Attorney
General's political agenda it is
abundantly clear that the Attorney
General's office has exceeded its
statutory Authority by prying into
transactions where absolutely no
wrongdoing has taken place again this is
Alina Hava who said that there was
nothing but a Declassified documents and
they were invisible documents that were
at Mar-A-Lago like every time she opens
her mouth and says something on Fox News
oan Newsmax whatever she's on it's a
dumb shitty legal take that even a
person who didn't go to law school
or isn't a lawyer knows that this is
awful this is terrible it is completely
100 wrong and this is just another one
of those things that is
is just dumb dumb [ __ ] like I don't
know how to put it like it's just it's
how long how long do you think before
Alina Haba has to uh lawyer up we know
Christina you know I I don't that's a
good question because here's the thing
so Christina Bob has been going around
and doing these uh Trump rallies she's
still talking she's interviewing people
you know like even this past weekend in
in Youngstown Ohio she was there
interviewing uh
uh Marjorie Taylor green and uh some
other people as well oh I even played
her yesterday or Monday I don't remember
which at the Time Slips Away here of her
interviewing a person in a Halloween
costume and I'm not [ __ ] you that's
not made up the person who was in the
Halloween costume said it was a
Halloween costume
I'm not making this [ __ ] I get you can't
even write this [ __ ] anymore I no I mean
no not at all it is you can't write this
[ __ ] anymore I mean you can trying to
try you well you can try yeah but you
can try but it's you can't even go far
enough here is a video it seems like a
new TV series or something that's coming
out you said yeah you tweeted it you
said breaking a New York attorney
general Leticia James just filed a civil
fraud lawsuit against the Trump crime
family and their Associates now I don't
know if this is uh this is this is put
out by our friend John Walsh so I don't
know if this is uh if this is a new TV
show look at this Trump crime family I
don't know there is a new there is a new
Wednesday Adams show coming on Netflix
so this could be in person oh I see yeah
I don't know but the Trump crimes should
we see that oh should we watch this
trailer to see what happens now here
here's what's gonna happen because
um we're going to post all these
episodes on YouTube once they lift our
band so when I post this episode on
YouTube their prop they may someone may
claim this music but I think John does a
pretty good job of tweaking it but let's
listen to the trailer here of the Trump
crime family maybe coming to Netflix
soon I I don't know maybe yeah I don't
know
they're sketchy and they're greedy
they're all together needy they call Joe
Biden sleepy the Trump friend family
[Laughter]
[Music]
a phrase that's understated the Trump
crime family
so there's the Trump crime family
um maybe maybe maybe coming to a
streaming streaming platform near you I
don't know maybe you'll find it on Pluto
TV behind you it could be it could be I
got the Pluto TV so this is this is
funny the Pluto TV here they have like a
Pluto TV news thing where it's just like
an aggregation of all kinds of news
stories so yeah like CBS ABC she get all
the all the fake news oh Gabe all the
Main Street back there what's going on
yeah well I don't know I don't know I
don't I don't I I I turn it the sound up
on it a little bit yeah um I don't
really watch the news that much to be
quite honest with you well you know
Twitter's a good news source honestly
yeah well I mean you know breaking new
stuff that happens absolutely well if if
you wanna if you want to go see the fake
news Twitter is the place to go that's
you know I mean that's what that's what
the fascists would say is you know you
got to go to you got to go to Twitter to
get your your daily dose of of fake news
speaking of Twitter why don't we do this
because we I got a video I want to show
you of a candidate out in Utah that we
just could not get to the last few days
okay but you think you think your satire
videos are funny oh my God this is real
and it is [ __ ] hilarious oh I think I
know who you're yes but we gotta show it
to the audience here so everyone
everyone sit tight we're gonna surf the
Tweety tweets and Eternity Trends as we
always do so Surf's Up let's go surfing
let's start the countdown
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the journey Michaels
podcast you have reached this shitless
Roundup where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and journey trends
and all this video I want to show it
because I don't want to forget it here
Gabe this video is absolutely insane
again you think you think your satire
videos are funny this lady outdid you
and she this is real life this is real
life this is real I just want to preface
this type of video is what you would
probably find on the early days of uh of
of YouTube or you would find on like
e-bombs world
for anything not to
date myself here
but what the hell is it what the hell is
that e-bomb's world yeah I don't [ __ ]
know oh my gosh anyone out there who
knows what e-bombs world please shine
like America's Funniest Home Videos like
it was a website that had a bunch of
dumb videos and prank stuff and like
everything oh so this was like a fat
kind of like a my the Myspace of YouTube
type thing or what kind of yeah yeah in
in and out in and out
yeah because you know there used to be
another website that I enjoyed a lot was
the people Walmart you remember this and
I know it probably still is out there
they probably still post a bunch of
stuff
um you know do you remember Homestar
Runner nope oh wow okay well never mind
never mind
basically it's like uh it's like a
Reddit YouTube version it's like oh my
dumb comedy humor ever you know anyway
but this type of content the way in
which she makes this video and goes
about it is oh you can't tell like I I'm
assuming she's like totally uh serious
on this but I can't tell
if the person who made this like who
edited it was like oh yeah got it I know
exactly what we're gonna do and how
we're gonna do it like if it's a if it's
a kid like it's a nephew or a grandson
or something uh who knows
but that's the like the whole style
that's what reminds me of so do you
think she wrote this because what we're
gonna watch is we're gonna watch this
lady and we're gonna watch her rap here
and this is like a campaign video I
don't think she wrote this I think
someone else wrote this and they got her
to do it and they're like this is a good
idea right yeah again like I don't know
if it was like a a nephew or a grandson
or whoever it is but they got her to say
look this is how you're gonna get those
young kids no cap Grandma you know uh
and then they wrote the lyrics and
obviously well we'll let everyone see
what she does well what I'm confused
about and this was a thing that really
confused me from the very beginning if
you look up here in the top left it says
IG which I I think it means Instagram
and then it says Utah satire so I'm
trying to figure out is you know now
everyone says this is real right it
doesn't feel real when you watch it
you're like this lady is totally making
fun of
conservatives and Republicans and Cuban
owners
and just this Maga Republican [ __ ]
like she's totally making fun of it from
what I understand though no one is
running against her okay so she is
running unopposed so why would she make
this video then
I don't
come on if she's running out of pose why
would you do such a stupid thing
hold on let's see Utah right maybe she
wanted to be internet famous I don't
know maybe I mean it's just like
um Linda Paulson right I you know you
got me here let's let's reaction let's
watch it let's watch it you go ahead and
look some this has got 4.1 4.4 million
views just right here and of course
across social media platforms it's
probably
um tens of millions of views
and you're about to find out why let's
let's watch this [ __ ] show in action
[Music]
hey Utah District 12. listen up right
here there's a new name on the ballot
for the Senate this year my name is
Linda Paulson Republican and awesome
love God and family and the Constitution
I tried to get another conservative to
run nobody could do it so I'm getting it
done I'm pro-religious Freedom pro-life
Pro police the right to bear arms and
the right to free speech I want less
government control and regulation want
to stop and expose all political
corruption where's Integrity morality
accountability government programs
should lead to self-sufficiency and
support traditional family as the
fundamental unit of society but in
schools they are pushing for new beliefs
and just to clarify this because there's
some who can't Define this as a female
adult I know what a woman is
[Music]
okay you heard it here uh Linda Polson
someone said in the chat Eminem's in
trouble
oh my God what in the actual [ __ ] is
this this commercial reminds me of like
a fake commercial like you know what
it's like the same style of like my Jim
trusty commercial or like a Better Call
Saul like they're like intentionally
crappy commercials right you know we
could play this in our breaks and it
peop our audience would be like this is
hilarious like literally right I can't I
can't tell I mean it could be this is
hilarious and people like I'm never
voting for Republican again this also my
people
I saw comments online that someone was
like well I'm a Democrat now
so like you know it isn't you mean like
this converted him to the George Soros
blood sucking cabal this video here I
mean because it's really
it's I'm still trying to figure out here
what's going on I mean like Andrew's
asking granny rap yes this is a granny
rap we're not yeah I mean this is we
didn't like this is this is something
that appeared on the internet but this
apparently is anything like that this is
apparently a person who is running on
the Republican ticket in Utah
um unopposed on the Republican side and
she even she even raps about it she even
um eloquently puts it in her lyrics that
no one else would run so she's getting
it done
um it's a quote
the ramp holy [ __ ] no I'm gonna tell you
I'm gonna tell you though that she did a
decent job ramping this out I mean it's
not like she didn't do a a good job I
mean she kept to the beat the the
editing like the you know the graphics
and stuff it's something left to be
desired but it's not surprising with you
know quote-unquote conservatives these
Mega Republicans they're horrible at
they're horrible at graphic design you
know that oh yeah no I uh it's like so
bad it's good in a way
um but I I look I look at her ballot
pedia kind of info here just to get an
idea oh okay yeah she's running for the
election of the U.S Senate to represent
District 12 she's on the ballot for
general election November 8th 2022
Republican uh primary for this office
was on June 28th was canceled because
obviously she was the only one running
she's born in Cedar City Utah Paul
Center ambassador's degree at BYU uh in
2007 her career experience includes
working as a homemaker
um so it's just a I guess I'm I'm stay
at home mom uh Paulson has been
affiliated with the daughters of the
Utah pioneers and the United women's
Forum which if I look up Daughters of
the Utah Pioneers is it a Mormon
organization
International Society Daughters of uh
Utah pioneers and women's organization
dedicated to preserving the history of
the original settlers of the geographic
area covered by the state of
the Utah territory including Mormon
pioneers so it sounds like a Mormon
organization right right if I had to
assume this isn't like based on what
we've seen and based on what I've read
unless this is some like deep deep Andy
Kaufman kind of bit this is real feel
like she is real she's 100 real again
could be wrong but holy [ __ ] man that'd
be like some deep undercover then once
you're there after saying you're a
republican say oh actually I have
Democratic Values uh to go forward with
she's running against a Democrat right
now Karen Maine yeah
um who is did she got a Twitter account
does she have a Twitter account Karen
Maine Karen Maine yeah um yeah she does
okay yeah yeah send me that link this is
this is one of the slides or one of the
graphics from the course you know it's
it's really shitty right I mean you know
you just don't do spacing like this you
know I get the red white and blue you
know I get the whole you know that kind
of thing yeah and but this looks like
something I would do really honestly
it's horrible
um but it says this is definitely not
like you would have to try to make it
this bad like a designer would be like I
need this to look awful
um I will say as a designer it's one of
the hardest things to do to make
something intentionally look bad it
takes way more effort
than you would think right because
you're constantly critiquing and be like
ah no I gotta move this that looks way
too good uh yeah like because I want it
to be here because of my brain Sands is
it another crazy New York Times what
phone am I using right right right but
here but here she says she's
pro-religious Freedom she's pro-life
she's Pro police she's Pro right to bear
arms and she's pro-free speech which I
would bet if you march down each one of
these issues she's actually against
every single one of these things like if
you if someone had the chance to sit
down and internet yeah yeah if you were
to go against and say oh do you like
everyone you know uh
uh practicing a religion no do you like
everyone to have guns no do you like
when the police go against you no
absolutely when somebody says something
mean about you no right like these are
all things that she would 100 and it's
the same thing that is true for
republicans and as a whole party
especially mag I talked about it earlier
where I mentioned how they are so
sensitive they don't want to be called
semi-fascists they don't want to be
associated with that they don't like
being uh people being mean to I mean
even Trump on true social was like why
is everyone so mean to me right well he
I as he is he truth yet today I know his
true thing about World War III once
start World War Three I don't know if
he's talking about teaching ah here we
go here we go yeah give me that give me
that link too uh Karen here is here is
um
um the the grandma rapper granny rampers
opponent the Democratic opponent Karen
is her name Karen Maine
um she's a senator from new so she's
currently from what I've read she's
currently this state center for District
Five she represents there so did they do
redistricting and stuff I believe
there's a because she says new District
12. so I believe there is redistricting
and things are allocated this is
probably why no Republican would run I
mean that would be my guess is because a
sitting Democrat is probably going to
win this District 12. you know I don't
know how they're redistrict out there
but right this is probably the reason
why I went and followed Karen because as
you see she is a proud mother a
grandmother
um so we have granny against granny here
um in in district 12 of Utah's state
senate race so uh show Karen some
support uh for the uh and maybe maybe we
could do man that would be great if we
could get like a wrap off I'm just
saying like a rap battle rap battle baby
oh man that would be [ __ ] awesome how
[ __ ] sweet would that be I mean we we
make politics a circus anyways these
days and these people are doing
unintentional satire themselves we might
as well have a wrap-off do you remember
the MTV I don't know if they still have
it but the MTV like rap Cipher no oh
well basically it's just like
freestyling oh we can put them on there
but yeah uh that would be cool yeah I
mean I I'm down for that now let's see
if I can get this what true social sucks
so bad look at this this is so horrible
this is the website here yeah you can't
even like you can't click on them it's
it's so shitty well they're like don't
copy what we have here you know
it's so shitty it's so shitty I'm gonna
have to go screenshot this and post it
on Twitter to make it look halfway
decent so this is this is 10 minutes ago
oh 10 minutes ago 10 minutes ago well
you need to grab this and go tweet
something about it then put something
about do I always I always I always do
the screen grab and I'm like dude does
something dude's freaking out uh 30
minutes ago I think or so 40 minutes ago
I tweeted I was like all right you know
uh meltdown on social in three two one
he took a minute obviously to write this
right out but uh but yeah he's what do
you what do you think the conversation
was with people before this this this
fraud social uh post here what do you
think the conversation was because I'm
gonna read this I have I haven't
actually read it yet I'm yeah I have it
up I haven't already yet but uh if I had
to imagine what the conversation was
right before this I'm sure he was uh
let's see it's it is one o'clock so he
heard it at 8 30 which is 11 30 Eastern
time well but he knew it before the
press conference because they actually
had it filed about 10 minutes before she
came out because I think that was the
delay they were trying to get the
lawsuit filed before the press
conference because they don't want to
come out and say we have a lawsuit that
we filed without it actually being
officially filed so they gotta wait for
it so I think that was the delay right
if I could imagine like somebody
probably came in moments before and said
hey uh you are being sued the whole
family's being sued and you're being
sued for 250 million dollars for
defrauding they're [ __ ] right you uh
inflated and he's like no I didn't even
though he really did uh and obviously he
had his attorneys you know Alina Hava
ready at the go she did not read that
222 page uh lawsuit no no way do you
think he's do you think he gave it to
her
oh yeah well I think I don't even think
he got it I think well I'm sure he was
served right like a whole well yeah they
have to what there would have to be some
sort of notification or something but I
I feel like you know eventually yeah and
I'm sure that you know she she got it in
some regard or she watched rather she
didn't get it but she watched Leticia
James give the announcement and then was
ready to go when they were contacted by
CNN and all these other Publications
um to say like oh this is complete
[ __ ] blah blah blah even though like
this is all based on fact she brought
the receipts but people like Alina Haba
obviously are pushing out this denial
denial denial
um and it's not going to work in the
long term but
I don't think that he actually read it I
don't think that she actually read it I
think that he heard kind the the lead on
it watched it
angrily crushed a Diet Coke can that he
was having for breakfast
uh you think he drinks Diet Coke for
breakfast oh hell yeah you think that's
what it is I've never seen him drink
coffee I've never seen him drink water
outside what about orange juice I mean
he's orange no no okay well I'm just I'm
just I'm just I don't think he drinks
orange juice uh this statement here I
just I just read it
um privately here in my own my own brain
here
and if you can imagine it's the I'm
rubber your glue
pepper you're going
literally he's accusing uh her of what
she's gonna sue him for and probably win
in New York Court and not only that
gonna get criminal referrals with the
evidence that she's collected to the IRS
and the sdy here's what he says let me
read this here for all the people
um listening out there to the podcast
directories by the way you should
download every single episode whether
you're watching or listening
um on Apple Spotify Google or your
favorite directory leave us a review
while you're there why you're
subscribing here's what Grandpa
Poopypants here's what the dude has to
say
on fraud social he writes types
meanders on here another Witch Hunt by a
racist
attorney general holy [ __ ] Leticia James
who failed in her run for governor which
she didn't fail she she said
specifically I'm not going to run for
governor is to take on this case against
Trump because it is highly important to
the state of New York he goes on getting
almost zero support from the public and
now is doing poorly against Law and
Order AG candidate either respected
Michael Henry which she will not lose to
Michael Henry here yeah not even a
chance dude New York [ __ ] hates Trump
right I was I was just talking to
someone and they would tell me a story
they saw him they were at a a fight in
Madison Square Gardens and he showed up
and everyone [ __ ] booed yeah because
they [ __ ] hate him they hate his
[ __ ] guts well and here's the other
thing too is that now I I wouldn't
imagine that there's probably
celebrations in the street of New York
today oh yeah probably we're probably
gonna see video footage of it he goes on
Grandpa Poopypants goes on to to word
salad here I never thought this case
would be he brought
okay until I saw her really bad poll
numbers
so he is claiming here that because she
has bad poll numbers whatever the [ __ ]
that means that this is the reason why
she brought this case so he's obviously
making the claim that she brought this
case
um to win an election which is kind of
funny because she's been investigating
this for a lot longer than I don't know
she's been re-running for Attorney
General of New York but also but also
the other thing too that that you know
ties in again this is always this is
Trump playing victim and whining about
he did the same thing this past weekend
in Youngstown Ohio where he said
everyone's out to get me and they're
attacking the Jan six Patriots and
forcing them and or blackmailing them to
say things that are mean against me
people aren't mean Gabe they are very
very mean because he was like oh they're
making them say stuff they're making
them say Trump's a bad person and I'm so
bad and blah blah blah blah blah and
then obviously he's like oh and they
want them to turn on me and say this and
say that
no evidence whatsoever that the
government is blackmailing anyone uh
they're charging them you know Law and
Order for the crimes they committed uh
for you know starting a riot causing
damage breaking and entering uh
threatening to kill people like all
these things it's not just like oh they
made it up and I'm the uh they're making
me the bad guy it's like you are the bad
guy and they did bad things for you
so it's the same this this rhetoric of
like uh oh she's only attacking me
because the poll numbers or whatever
it's like no there's actual Merit behind
the uh the interest to prosecute you for
these he's he's such a [ __ ]
um Raider rain points out here on Twitch
he is displayed in Chicago too there's
so many pictures of people giving the
finger so when we went to Chicago the
last time and could you take the you
take the uh um the bus tour what the
hell is it called
um well there's a boat tour there's an
art well yeah there's yeah there's a
boat tour bus tour that takes you down
like right it takes you right past Trump
Tower they talk about it and there's so
many pictures like people in on the top
of the double decker bus the open bus of
them flipping off I actually took a
picture of myself living off the Trump
episode did my wife so I can I can also
confirm as a fellow chicagoan uh we
[ __ ] hate Trump and we hate that
[ __ ] tower that he has but not only
that I mean the funniest part about it
was the fact that that Tower is
unfinished right they never got because
well they never he never finishes
anything well never yeah because they
were Stormy Daniels confirmed that he
never finishes anything uh like just
like him it was a little shorter than
expected right or I guess he would
expect him to be pretty short but right
well any any well in the building he
doesn't he do the same thing he does in
every building claim it's more floors
than it is because he's got to talk
about how how much bigger it is than it
actually is chopped off the tip and they
said we can't do it we can't do it gotta
chop the tip off and they said because
they did not have enough uh interest to
actually lease out the property because
that's what they're doing basically they
didn't have enough money to fund the
building straight up they had to wait
for enough interest to then uh you know
price out and actually build out the
construction of those top floors but
they said okay [ __ ] it and then just put
a tall antenna or whatever is all there
well um Flynn is a Trader here on um
twitch points out so he inflates the
square footage well that's part of the
scheme that this James laid off today so
so he goes on to say here in his little
fraud show social post about I I why did
he call a racist attorney general I
don't understand that well because Trump
believes that you can be racist against
him I don't know maybe because he's like
oh that's orange you're not white uh
what the [ __ ] does that even so he's
saying because she's black and he's
white she's a racist is that what he's
saying here that's what I believe so I
mean the thing is it's this is not just
why why why do white people think that
black people can be racist against white
people do they know what racism even
[ __ ] is no do they know the history
have they have they done any Research
into why racism in this country is
against the blacks mainly in the first
place I don't think they have
um so calling her the racist attorney
general only projects that he's a
[ __ ] racist and he wants to call her
the n-word here that's basic to me that
to me that's what I'm reading here
honestly that's what I'm reading now he
goes on to say at the end of the
statement here he says she is a fraud
who campaigned on a get Trump in quotes
platform he actually uses these air
quotes appropriately here this is
amazing I want the breaking news Donald
Trump uses air quotes in his post here
appropriately
he says get Trump platform despite the
fact that the city I don't know why he's
saying City not stayed here is the one
of the crime and murderer disasters of
the world under her watch why she is not
the Attorney General of the city she's
Attorney General of a state what the
hell is he talking this is this makes
about as much sense as calling her
racist right this is something that's
like oh if you have a problem with the
city maybe we should go to right the
mayor I don't know and I don't know
which city he's talking about because
because the capital of New York is not
in New York City now I mean most people
don't know that maybe he doesn't know
that I don't know are you surprised he
wouldn't know that well not really I
mean I mean you would think a guy who
defrauded the state in New York would
know where the [ __ ] capital is right
well the guy couldn't couldn't point out
Puerto Rico on a map he could you know
he he had to draw with the Sharpie the
extension of where the hurricane was
going to come into Florida right this
guy AI doesn't know geography does no
basic facts he whenever someone says
you're wrong he goes you're wrong fake
news that's what he does I mean just
this past weekend again at the which I
have what was that coming out uh on his
speech in Ohio he said Caravans I
invited I invented the phrase Caravans
just like uh crooked Hillary just like
fake news like that that is the guy
we're dealing with the guy is so petty
that he has to come he's like I I
invented the word Caravan if that's so
true then I believe that you know
Webster's Dictionary would like to have
a word about well Dodge Dodge may have
uh something to say about that too they
got the Dodge carrier exactly okay so
Barbara I don't know if it's Barbara or
Frankie are posting us on Facebook but
says yes Tony that is what Trump is
saying I don't know
um what exactly you're saying that is
true but maybe it's about the racist
comment that he's making races just
because I see other people in here
because I'm telling you now a lot of
people are gonna be you know little
cringe of me saying this but this is me
being a white white dude reading this
statement from Donald Trump and knowing
white people the way they are because
folks I grew up in Rural America
um I've I've heard my share of black
people jokes and this is this is me
interpreting this as his supporters his
sheep his Q Anon cult here that he was
trying he's trying to stoke to violence
I mean he's a not so subtle dog whistle
well right I mean he's definitely I
believe he is directly calling her
uh the n-word here that is exactly what
he's doing I think that's right John Jr
has also said similar things and there's
a right they call her a racist and [ __ ]
which is uh again like you're saying is
a dog whistle but more than that I think
I think they're actually
um
showing their their their little Q Anon
violent cult here that hey yeah that's
what we think she is
she is what you want this so
um there is there's the first freak out
from the I'm surprised
yeah oh there is oh here's another one
oh yeah okay here we go here we go
here's another one uh he's gonna be in
full freak out mode all day long we
could probably sit here for for five
hours and just read his [ __ ] just his
nonsense and his freak out here on on on
fraud social here we go with another one
um I don't know why I have no idea
here's another nickname this probably
has to do with again the racist comments
in the last one uh and and what he the
dog whistle that he's trying to uh to to
send out here
um grapple booby pants
post 13 minutes ago in his uh freak out
rage rants here he says attorney general
Leticia peekaboo in quotes James
obviously that's the nickname he's given
her now peek-a-boo I'm not sure
speakaboos the game is like oh peekaboo
but maybe he's that maybe he's a baby
maybe he's admitting he's a big baby and
she's playing peek-a-boo with him I'm
here I don't I have no idea he goes on
to say a total crime-fighting disaster
in New York here we go again with the
city line to a Marvel movie
the total crime fighting disaster in New
York I mean you can you can voice this
thing I guess it's he goes on is
spending all of her time fighting for
very powerful and well-represented Banks
and insurance guy oh so here's what he's
claiming he's claiming that now she is a
sycophant for banks and insurance
companies here's the thing here's the
thing the problem that he has here with
the bank statement is that that's why
she's referring the criminal charges to
the sdny and the IRS is because they
have jurisdiction well the state of New
York does have because wall Street's
there there are some Bank headquarters
in New York so they have some
jurisdiction but the financial crimes
are really they're under Federal
statutes is where that battle is going
to be wage so uh he doesn't quite under
now insurance companies are a little
different story in terms companies
um are under the purview of most States
now there are federal statutes to do
with insurance but most States
um actually use their statutes to
um regulate insurance companies and
that's actually what the that's actually
what the Obamacare the Affordable Care
Act did was try to have more Federal
oversight than just state by state by
state so it's not a patchwork of laws
it's you know more coherent
um he goes on to ramble here who were
fully paid made a lot of money and never
had a complaint about me instead of
fighting murder and violent crime which
is killing New York state so now he's
back to New York's the state not the
city so he saw the error of his ways in
his first little
um whiny little [ __ ] uh fraud social
post here and now he's back to New York
State not the city but here's the thing
um and before I finish the uh the the
the crazy
word salad here he is absolutely wrong
when he says the banks and the the
insurance companies and all that made
money what it what Tish James is saying
is the banks lost money because what
happens is when you over value a
property to receive a loan if you
default on that loan the bank can lose
money and when you're you're
fraudulently actually claiming that it's
worth more than it is to receive the
loan that's the fraud and the reason why
it's fraud is because you're essentially
stealing money from the bank if you have
a possible default in your contract
which we know Donald Trump loves the
default and that's that's what the
Attorney General is actually making the
claim here so he is doing more
projection than this word salad post he
goes on to say she is a failed AG which
obviously now that she's brought a
lawsuit against him she she's failed um
whose lack of talent in the fight
against Crime is causing record numbers
of people and companies to flee New York
bye bye I mean your you your family and
your allies are leaving New York for
sure I mean that's uh something that
you've been trying to do for a long time
to try to skate your criminal and civil
liability here I think that's another
thing that I want to point out again to
the audience
is this is not a criminal case she's
making criminal referrals which I think
actually is one of the most significant
parts of this I actually think 250
million dollars is probably not enough
because they won't get the full 250
million bucks
um I I doubt I doubt that's I mean I
don't you know I'm sure the 250 is based
on whatever calculation from previous uh
properties and business kind of dealings
that have been misled through uh uh
fraudulent inflation or over inflation
of of value so I'm sure they have some
calculator just like they have a
calculator to say like oh this is what
you know a a family member was passed
away this is what they attribute to them
being Worth right so I would I would
imagine the same thing as being done
here where they go through the receipts
and they say this is what it did here
this one yeah this actually runs you
know in parallel with this so this is
the total amount we expect probably a
summary or like a
uh Louisiana weekly says the hard truth
peekaboos I don't know if this has
something to do with it can you look
that up sorry yeah I didn't mean to cut
you off there no no I was just saying
that um it's you know his claim of it's
unfair and no one ever had a complaint
against me oh boy that is not true well
it's not true if you go back and you
look at Trump history and we're talking
you know you're going back over 30 years
now
um to look at what happened in the late
80s early 90s with Trump and Banks
literally the guy was spending Banks
money to to have parties and big lavish
things and go on Jets from one place to
the other and the banks actually cut him
off they were they were dictating his
daily expenses at the bank like no you
can't spend money on that Donald that's
not something you can spend money on you
owe us way too much and U.S banks
stopped doing business with him that's
why he went to like Deutsche Bank he
started to finance stuff overseas in
Russia with oligarchs and stuff
um and and then he started you really
learned that you can launder money
through some of his real estate deals in
foreign countries with with Russians
money because like you said a lot of the
buildings that he's built are are had a
hand in a lot of them are sitting half
empty and they sell those apartments
empty Apartments
empty apartments in those buildings as
if they're real Floyd furnace Apartments
there are there are certain Russian ties
that have whole floors
James actually laid out um part of that
where one of the schemes is they would
claim on the listing of the apartment
that it was three times the size it
actually was and they would sell it
based on that price knowingly
um and they have to have evidence that
they knew that that's what they were
doing here right um so I mean it's
really fun I mean I I again you know I'm
not a lawyer you're not a lawyer but I
would be curious to know like if this
civil lawsuit is brought against him for
doing this could a class action lawsuit
be be put against them by the people who
have previously lived there or been
tenants to say that you misled on the
price you know I I um I guess that's a
good question but in this lawsuit
against Donald Trump for the state of
New York that the the
um the actual money that the lawsuit is
seeking the 250 million bucks is the tax
money because that's the thing when he
over inflates a property for a bank loan
which is bank fraud that's the bank
fraud that's the criminal referrals that
she's going to make to the federal
government which is not good for Trump
because if she's making criminal for all
that means she has evidence which means
she's turning over the evidence
um to the sdmy which is significant
because they have his tax returns folks
they got his [ __ ] tax returns now the
the fraud on this side of the state of
New York where she's seeking to get the
250 million bucks is where he
undervalues that same property they
overvalued for the bank loan he
undervalues that property to pay less
property tax which is part of the
double-ended scheme now he writes about
this in [ __ ] books I actually have
books on my shelf here where him and
Robert Kiyosaki write about this where
you you undervalue an overvalue on the
bookends right when you're on the end of
the bank you overvalue when you're on
the end of taxes you undervalue which
you can do to some legal extent right
because generally speaking there's
um there's kind of like
I mean there's
there's
a way to figure out in each state and
each state is a little different they
have a formula to figure out what the
property's worth and then how much
you're going to pay in property tax and
a lot of it has to do with the
jurisdiction that the property actually
resides in
um but so there's certain ways to
undervalue which most property is
undervalued at a tax level in Most
states and when you go look at it but he
was actually knowingly
devaluing this property to get his taxes
down on one end and knowingly way
overvaluing the property to defraud the
bank right so he's defrauding both the
bank and the state of New York and the
people of New York on both ends of one
property and that is actually the scheme
and how he's making that's how he's
making a bit of money here is because
he's paying way less taxes on that
property by undervaluing it and getting
way more money when he sucks cash out of
these properties to to run around in his
private jets and pretend he's a
billionaire because really at the heart
of that that's what it is right and this
isn't just like a one-off you know and
she Leticia James she's like this isn't
just like a one-off thing this wasn't
done like oops I accidentally you know
miscalculated something about this is
over a 10-year period
of fraudulent false and misleading
representation what she does 10 years
because that's probably the statute of
limitation that she has in that 10 years
200 plus times that he has d uh that is
fraudulently valued the Val uh his
assets so uh 200 false and misleading
valuations over a 10-year period I mean
like that's over only 10 years now
imagine like what it would have been
like all the way back to 1970 or
whatever when he started you know
working with well his dad his dad is his
father did this a lot too right right
it's him he um he learned this from his
father in Roy Cohen is who he learned
this from
um here is a tweet from Wu-Tang is for
children
um Leticia James with an epic mic drop
to close out her presser and he quotes
Tish James here in other words
permanently prohibit any of these
companies from doing business in the
state of New York let's listen to this
little clip from the press conference
here
and last thing
to cancel any certificate filed under
and by virtue of the provisions of
section 130 of the general business law
for the corporate entities named as
defendants and any other entity
controlled by or beneficially owned by
Donald Trump which participated in or
benefited from the ongoing Financial
scheme
in other words
permanently prohibit any of these
companies
from doing business
in the state of New York
so in other words the Trump organization
and any organization is associated with
it is no longer going to be able to do
business in the state it would also be
interesting would be to see other cities
or states take this as precedent once
obviously they go through everything but
take it as president and say based on
his behavior in this state and what he's
done we don't want him to also be able
to operate in our state because he is
either defrauding financial institutions
uh he is uh cheating his way out of
paying taxes right you know like I I
could imagine potentially
that other people jump on board maybe
down the road to say yeah we don't want
him operating our city either we don't
want him operating our state because he
is a stain on our economy well but Gabe
they've already done this even with his
rallies like this is the reason why he
had a lot of these rallies and like
cattle fields and cheap Fields sheep
Fields not to well because he won't pay
too much right so so he has to go have
him in these in these open pastures
because he doesn't have to some farmer
will let them use their pasture for
parking and the rally
um so he doesn't have to pay because a
lot of cities won't even let him in
their City to have events and the reason
why is because these have he doesn't he
owes money to Arizona uh in Ohio like
this last a young Youngstown it wasn't a
trump rally it wasn't a trump rally
because they owned money they had to do
it under the guise of of masteriano and
him supporting these [ __ ] uh these
um well Youngstown Ohio excuse me
Youngstown Iowa JD Vance and these other
[ __ ] idiots can you believe that
dewine went along with it
can you believe that [ __ ]
it is it is it is something I mean I see
JD Vance he's a he's a [ __ ] fraud
he's a phony he's such a piece of [ __ ]
but dewine dewine actually showed some
sensibility but all of it went out the
window for me when he when he went and
he posed with him and he took his
endorsement I can't believe that dewine
thinks he's it's a winning a winning
um
a winning platform of trump here
especially now that we're gonna see uh
the chips fall for this guy even after
this election what do you think about
that that's crazy
I will say this like the
I mean that okay the rally the wine is
huge [ __ ] yes yes Scott Scott on
Facebook says the wine is a huge [ __ ]
well I mean well here the last time I
heard dewine's name is when he tried to
get uh people to take the vaccine and so
he was creating incentives to say we'll
give you free college tuition if you get
the vaccine wasn't that what what no he
was I think yeah he was a lottery yeah
it was a lottery yeah he was giving away
like Hey we're giving they were giving
away like a hundred thousand dollars or
some [ __ ] there's a lot of [ __ ] money
I was surprised at that but okay even
even in this because because uh the
federal government actually gave that
money for the states to give away to
incentivize it and dewine did like a
lottery where he get they give away a
big chunk of change some of the states
were giving away like 100 bills like
they pay you to go get to go get
vaccinated we'll just inject you with us
right so right so instead of using the
federal money as one big pot they would
give it away as little little things but
yeah I mean like even watching the rally
this past weekend it was in
same the amount of Q Anon Maga merging
that was happening at this place right
like
at each rally right as as and I talk
about this and what was that but like as
we ramp up to the midterm elections in
November like
Trump is just like ratcheting up his
rallies his speeches are getting more
deranged delusional claims I mean
they're given the not the the Q Anon
Nazi salute while he's he's Jim's
jonesing into the microphone right why
they're playing the Q Anon theme song
it's [ __ ] weird man it looks [ __ ]
weird I think the funniest part about
that too is like you bring up a good
point right he can't have a trump rally
so he has to do it under a name of oh
this is a JD van right rally right right
but here's the thing Trump goes up there
for you know hour hour and a half two
hours and [ __ ] just rants right and
it's these rallies yeah they're like
stump for these candidates but they're
mainly for Trump to talk about himself
and to just talk about random [ __ ] like
if anything mentioned of him oh I'm the
victim and they're Prosecuting me I want
you to get mad and angry and I want you
to go out and have a physical you know
incite violence and it is the same thing
right like at this rally too he gets
under the label of JD Vance I'm here to
support you which he also says JD Vance
is kissing my ass and he goes oh yeah JD
Vance that's a not so nice things to say
but once you met him he loved him he
loved me too
but it's that same type of [ __ ] where
he will give any any excuse to talk
about himself he will make it about
himself whenever he can well that's the
way his his uh his sycophants is a
little Q Anon uh cult followers we'll
we'll talk about him great like Jeremy
Johnson does here on the Facebook jet I
don't like to point out Jeremy because
he's a he's a dumb [ __ ] but uh he tells
panty Glenn that he should repent repent
and quit supporting Tony Michaels and
here's the thing Jeremy you know what
you know what's funny about this Tish
James thing Gabe and that Jeremy doesn't
understand because I'm sure Jeremy's
given plenty of money to Trump and Trump
save America pack his legal defense I
don't know how many times he's uh
refinanced his home right and the other
thing too is he's probably given to the
RNC did you know did you know the RNC is
paying his legal bills for this civil
and criminal case in New York they are
literally using political donations to
to [ __ ] pay the legal bills in the
state of New York now the RNC has said
not on the documents not on the
classified documents they said do not
run if you run right we will not right
we're not we're going to stop paying
your legal bills in New York and
anywhere else because they're footing
the bill for all these these the the
legal cost that's happening to Trump
personally right not not politically
this doesn't have what him doing being
president or running as a candidate this
has to do with him his family his
personal business they're playing paying
legal bills and Jeremy you really are
cute when you come in here and try to
defend and Trump as your as your Q Anon
cult leader it really is it really is
cute of you and it's really sweet of you
to come in and defend him but you don't
have to do that anymore you don't have
to send him any money you really
shouldn't send the RNC any money because
it's gonna go to a failed legal defense
of him being civilly brought and he's
gonna pay a lot of [ __ ] money and
they're gonna chop that down the Trump
Tower they're gonna chop it down like a
fresh cut tree and you're gonna be
really sad that you gave all that money
to the RNC and Trump especially when
you've got to save America Super PAC
that Trump has and that also is used
however he wants to be confused right
you you give money and they say okay
great we'll give a little bit to his
legal fund a little bit of the paying
off the debts uh we'll give a little bit
to the RNC which is like I don't know
less than 20 now or something like that
but it has gone from uh it was a 60 40
split to a 75-25 split to something even
less for the RNC but again the money
that you go to his legal defense fund
the save America pack like all this
stuff goes directly to paying off his
debts so he gets in more debt by doing
these things and you continue to pay off
those yeah it is a this is exactly like
the friend who's like Hey look
I don't have a lot of cash right now I
need 500 bucks to pay well no they say
like I need
515.25 cents they always tell you at
like an exact amount like an exact
amount but the behavior that Trump has
is when he says hey he's like that
friend who comes to you and says hey man
look times are tough I just need like
500 bucks to cover my rent and the next
paycheck will come through and then the
next month they're like look I need like
800 bucks uh I was I didn't work as many
hours I didn't do this be Ultra Mega
give me 800 bucks for my rent
yeah uh I don't know they're just paying
him to pay to exist I don't know if
Lee's I don't know who Lisa's flipping
off here on Facebook hey no no can
anyone confirm if Lee I don't know if
Lisa's I don't think she is but maybe
she is one of these uh Q Anon cultists
in the in the Facebook Chat finger was I
don't know I don't it's it's hard to
keep up with it yeah it's hard to keep
up with the chat but um but if you're
giving me the middle finger for going
after Jeremy if that is the reason Lisa
um I I'm happy to receive the bird and
that's actually the reaction that I
would look for from a q Anon Trump
supporter is the bird when I go after
someone like Jeremy because you know
[ __ ] Jeremy right um but if it's not and
it's directed too yeah if it's directed
to Jeremy I absolutely would love to
have the bird than that that way too
oh let's let's watch another clip of
Tish James absolutely neutering Donald
Trump here this one's great let's watch
this following a comprehensive
three-year investigation by my office
including Witnesses interviews with more
than 65 Witnesses and review of millions
of documents that were submitted by Mr
Trump and others
I am announcing that today
we are filing a lawsuit against Donald
Trump
for violating the law
as part of his efforts to generate
profits for himself his family and his
company
the complaint demonstrates that Donald
Trump falsely inflated his net worth by
billions of dollars to unjustly enrich
himself
and to cheat this system
thereby cheating all of us
there you have it Alisa confirms you it
wasn't for me it was for someone else
there's a there's a part of me that
thinks in an uh
just an alternate universe or timeline
that if Trump never ran for president
he might still be that's what I said in
the first 30 minutes man if he would if
he would have came down that escalator
and he said I hate brown people I'm a
racist and done all this little trumpy
things and then said but I'm not running
because it's not my time and there's
other people blah blah blah we wouldn't
be having these conversations number one
this change would have never looked into
him they would have never got his tax
returns he would have skated by he'd be
continuing to launder money for Russians
he would be continuing uh to do his
little tax Rod scheme here where he does
his valuation scheme where he he takes
off millions of dollars of people's
money he would continue to do I mean you
know it we've talked about it for before
before which is like you know kind of
shiny the the best disinfectant is
sunlight but
this is one of those things where it's
like that sunlight might not it might
have been covered by a cloud you know if
if Trump had not stepped out from that
escalator and gave this I am announcing
to run for president and now yes he is a
uh you know he's more or less a a
household name people know Trump and
known for this The Apprentice Tower blah
blah all this stuff uh you know there
are people underneath that say oh he is
a fraud he's a fake he's this he's that
but when you put someone on a national
stage especially as the president like
and also as president You're Now using
your power and your influence to better
yourself and your family in an illegal
way right you do all these things like
take classified documents you try to you
know
Lobby money for build the wall Steve
bannon's think that he got charged and
indicted for right these are all these
things that you begin to wonder if he
wasn't president he didn't run for
president he didn't have that power he
didn't have that influence would we be
here today or if we did you know would
it have been a longer time down the road
and in addition to that is like if it
wasn't if it if he did not put himself
in the spotlight to a worldwide stage
really
with the people that have worked with
him in the past come forward right we
see Jan six it wasn't only it was it was
just because of Jan 6 in the committee
hearings that these people were willing
to come forward based on the subpoenas
they received to say yeah I was here and
he said that and we did that and blah
blah blah but like again if he never
became present none of this I mean
outside we would never have in an
Insurrection but none of this in terms
of the legal woes that he's going
through probably would have been a
problem
I I can't agree with you more and um
there's a lot of people posting about
this uh Tish James conference and
posting a lot of Clips uh from the
conferences about 30 minutes long and
she just kept burying him and bearing
and bearing him under me Underneath more
and more evidence right
um of the financial crimes but I think
also a significant
um one of the pieces of news here is
that not only is it Trump it's his
family it's Eric yeah Don Jr and Ivanka
which are going to that is going to seek
sanctions through the court order I'm
wondering if the criminal referrals
and we'll also include those family
members that was kind of unclear at this
point if it to me I thought the criminal
referrals were also including done did
that well because again I was trying to
set up the stream and get it going and
listen at the same time so I may have
missed that so if we can find that if
the criminal referrals are going to draw
in uh the family members not just the
organization and Trump himself and then
Alan weisenberg because we know that the
kids um as much as they pretended to be
business people on The Apprentice and in
real life look at me I'm a business
person
um that uh that they also were involved
in the Trump organization because you
remember when he became president
remember the the fake fraud that he did
where he had a table full of uh blank
paper and he's like oh I'm giving all my
business away decisions ability away to
my kids and it was just a table full of
blame and he had some [ __ ] Cracker
Jack attorney come out and say something
about oh yeah we're gonna we're gonna
make sure that the kids are the ones can
join the business know one of the kids
was in the [ __ ] white house right and
the other ones were in the white house
all the time not officially but
unofficially but here's the thing
do you remember
the because this reminds me of uh of
[ __ ] statements that he made yeah he
was debating the email lady
and he was talking about how much taxes
he doesn't pay do you remember this and
he said it's because I'm what did he say
he said because I'm a smart businessman
I'm a good businessman what did he say I
think he said it's because he's smart I
gotta say today his Brilliance right
is on Full display here with this James
do we have any more um let's see oh yeah
the uh on the criminal referral yes
Donald Trump Jr does include them Donald
Trump Don Jr Eric Trump and Ivanka and
the Trump organization to the IRS
Criminal Division and the U.S attorney's
office for the sdny so it does include
them yeah yeah
did we ever track down what the peekaboo
statement meant did we ever track that
down so because he he called her
peek-a-boo right right I was trying to
read the article while we're
simultaneously doing this I did not get
an answer I saw some other people saying
that it was uh
it was a trans statement but some people
are saying the peekaboo means the n-word
I I don't know I I I only yeah I've
never heard of them trying to read it
but uh but when I I mean
it goes to show you that immediately
when I heard peekaboo I thought oh this
is some racist kind of thing that he's
nicknamed right
um uh or just like if it's not that it's
some other slur of some kind but
yeah uh wouldn't be surprised but it
seems like the people in the chat here
are confirming that the it is a slur uh
it means the n-word yeah well I mean
it's
um yeah because I I know I know wait
wait wait wait that's a different one
though yeah I don't know unless he
unless he [ __ ] it up but I'm I don't
know well because because uh a um a very
derogatory term is that that is used in
place of the n-word has the has the
rhythm of of peek-a-boo but it starts
with jig
um and and and that comes from the the
sound of the n-word yeah um and they
they white people racist white people
say that all the time trust me I know
this
um look at look at the trends here we've
got we've got Tiffany Trump trending and
probably because she's not on the list
Tiffany's like baby thank God he [ __ ]
doesn't even know who I am Baron's
probably
thank God he doesn't know who I am
um ketchup is trending I wonder
listen when when when Tish James the
Attorney General of the state of New
York
um brings a civil 250 million dollar
civil case against Trump his family and
his organization and then refers crimes
to the IRS and the southern district of
New York
um and ketchup is trending you know
exactly why right you know exactly and
you can't make this [ __ ] up these are
things these are things we wouldn't know
about ketchup unless it were for the Jan
6 committee right well and and Cassidy
Hutchinson right right because she
described how when she came in the room
the the White House staff person was
cleaning the ketchup off the wall
because he played the porcelain and she
described it down the wall just so
ketchup all over ketchup is trending uh
Lisa she's laughing at ketchup trending
here at least again I apologize
um I I now know that you were giving the
middle finger to someone not to me so
much love there in the Facebook Chat
keep coming back and really honestly to
the haters keep coming back I like that
fake cave and Jeremy come here and and
sycophant for trump it gives us
something to do it gives us fake fake
game really he does a lot you know right
there's a lot of uh
uh
a lot of uh right-wing conspiracy talk
on his end
um
love it love it well here's Dan rather's
tweet he's he's trending because of this
I think Trump's not on Twitter to see
that New York attorney general Leticia
James is trending
but one thing has one but one has to
imagine that she is also trending in his
head oh she is gonna live rent free
inside his head and on his fraud social
page for quite some time Dan Rather yeah
he's got some great tweets by the way
who would have who would have thought
that Dan Rather would become a prolific
Tweeter huh he is I mean you know sharp
wit and uh quick get quick to the
twitters you know I guess if you could
if you can put it in a few in a few
words just a few characters few hundred
characters that quick wit comes in handy
every once in a while
um of course president Donald Trump is
trending here let's go to the let's go
to the trends I'll show you I'll show
you what's what's going on here on
Twitter
um
Leticia James is trending number one
obviously with the hashtag Trump crime
rambling and trying Trump Goes to Jail
which again this is a civil case but the
most important part about this as far as
criminally is she's giving criminal
referrals to the federal government
meant yeah and the Department of Justice
and the IRS which is very important hey
twitch is trending
um and oh and gambling yeah they're uh
they're trying to Tamp down some of the
gambling stuff over onto which I guess
the live streaming of gambling sites you
know we're on Twitch you can watch us
yeah she's on Twitch right now that's
right we are live on Twitch um Putin is
trending because he's freaking out
because he's kind of like a a caged
animal kind of like his buddy Trump his
butt buddy Trump so he's kind of
freaking out over the war in Ukraine
he's uh pounding his chest Trump was
tweeting about it earlier in support of
Putin like yeah don't mess with him or
he'll start World War Three he'll he'll
he'll do it I promise him [ __ ] uh
Sean King is trending
um this is is this the game this is the
end this is probably really gross I'm
sure the masses Millions dollars in
donations
um
oh the 2020 murder of George for a while
its signature project to review and
redress yeah The Daily Beast has they've
done a few kind of exposes on uh on Sean
King and his dealings with just the
black lives matter movement and you know
the the summer and fall of 2020 but yeah
like
basically he's a he's a fraud
um yeah I'm sure he's gonna be in a lot
of trouble let's see what else do we
have oh brag brag is training brag is
the uh the new
um he's he's the Manhattan D.A yeah
right he's the one that's gonna try the
case against the Trump organization the
criminal case because folks that's the
thing here as much as fake Gabe won't
say this is all civil it's all civil you
can't do nothing it's all civil and
you're not gonna blah blah blah blah
listen there is a criminal
case that has charges criminal charges
against the same company
for the same thing that tis James is
going to bring a civil lawsuit here's
the difference the criminal lawsuit has
a much higher bar of proof
to actually charge him with crimes and
and actually make them pay money yeah
the civil lawsuit at the Attorney
General's office has a much lower bar
so Bragg has his work cut out for him
here but I would imagine uh as Tish
James laid out today that Alan
weissenberg knows a lot about these
frauds yeah and now that he's
cooperating against them boom where is
the concrete evidence well well we'll
see it in trial yeah we'll see it in
trial and I don't know why sober yeah
200 Page lawsuit well not only that but
I'm I'm saying in the criminal trial
we're going to see the concrete evidence
in the criminal trial
um and and Alan weiserberg is going to
be cooperating with prosecutors against
the Trump organization so uh here here
we go here we go here Aries says
criminal lawsuit no it's criminal
charges Gabe fake Gabe there's criminal
charges filed and indicted against the
Trump organization in the Manhattan DA's
office dummy the same case the same
conspiracy that Alan weisselberg has
pled guilty in where he's going to
cooperate against the Trump organization
in a criminal trial you need to pluck
your head out of your [ __ ] ass that's
what I've been telling you I've been
telling him trying to tell you in the
chat man I'm trying to save you I'm
trying to help you fake Gabe I'm trying
to help you with the truth I'm trying to
feed you a true sandwich you won't
[ __ ] listen pluck your head out of
your Q Anon ass
and understand that there are criminal
charges
they're going to go to trial for crimes
in the state of New York for the Trump
organization that same organization that
tis James filed a lawsuit against this
morning is under criminal indictment in
the state of New York you dumb
[ __ ] go look at that concrete
concrete evidence
stupid bastard okay let's see um uh oh
you're saying back off the mic am I am
am I getting a little well you're
because I think well am I getting a
little heavy had the mic up here yeah
I'm getting a little heavy down so
you're fine
my mic my mic my mic strategy with the
new placement is off I apologize I just
get I get pissed off I get pissed off
when I get I'll back up I'll back up
when I get pissed off
listen
um I I just I just I just want I just
want fake Gabe to understand that when
you come here and listen to the Tony
Michaels podcast you keep saying that
we're lying and we're not telling the
truth and we're a bunch of George Soros
sycophants or antifa or whatever you're
saying now we are antifa for sure I'm
anti-fascist but what I say about the
Trump organization and the criminal and
civil lawsuits is just the evidence that
has gathered in the full public view
right now here's the thing
if if it's such an injustice and they're
doing such an injustice to Trump and
only Trump well why do you think that is
you dummies why do you think that is do
you think it's because that no other
attorney general anywhere in the red
States will try and prosecute Hillary
Clinton
do you think that's the case or do you
think the reason why they can't
prosecute these democrats for political
crimes and have a political try it's
because there's no evidence there is
none you [ __ ] idiots the evidence is
mounted against him because he's a fraud
that is what he has been so long he has
done things that were legal but let's
also keep in mind
if Trump was innocent and and you know
as fake Gabe says there's no evidence
there's nothing concrete this and that
like you have to then ask yourself
why is no
attorney taking this up right why is no
one jumping on the bandwagon to say yeah
Trump is like and when I say attorney
obviously we have Jim trustee we have uh
Alina have a Christina Bob these are all
joke joke lawyers right people that are
that
frauds in and of themselves really but
if if this really was a an open and shut
case and Trump was you know uh wrongly
persecuted and he was not
you know a criminal like they believe
for all these various things whether he
was during his presidency or outside of
his presidency then why are there not
actual legitimate high-ranking power
attorneys [ __ ] begging to take this
on if you were someone like that
and you took on a case that [ __ ] Pro
big profile that National Global stage
and walked away and were like yeah I
beat the government oh my God please
direct me to what law firm or lawyer or
or whoever is taking that case on
because right now it seems like almost
all of them is deciding to say uh uh I'm
backing the [ __ ] off from this because
this is too toxic I don't want to be
wrapped up in this drama and I know if I
do this I'm not going to get [ __ ]
paid
and that's the truth of it well here's
here's one last statement before we go
from again the Trump Q Anon sycophant
fake Gabe over on Facebook I'm glad get
fake Gabe I'm really glad you're here to
give us this type of stupidity so we can
put it up on the T and knock it out of
the park here because you're saying and
fake Gabe says here the ages belief is
not a it's not a charge with quotes
around it okay I'm I'm telling you I'm
telling you
I don't give a [ __ ] what happened today
about the AG and Tish James that's not
what I'm saying you stupid bastard
listen to the words that come out of my
mouth
there is criminal charges an actual
charge not a belief not a belief it's a
charge against the Trump organization in
this in the Manhattan DA's office
also in that conspiracy for that
criminal charge are you listening to the
[ __ ] words I'm saying charge
Alan weisselberg the Chief Financial
Officer who is also part of this
uh civil lawsuit
listen
Alan weisselberg has pled guilty to
those criminal
charges criminal not civil criminal
[ __ ] gonna go to jail
and the condition of him having a
slightened jail sentence from the judge
go read the [ __ ] judges statement
dummy is that he has to cooperate
against the Trump organization in this
case that is the deal that was made with
Alan weiselberg to take a guilty a
guilty plea to plead down the charges so
he gets a lesser sentence
pluck your head out of your Q Anon ass
and listen to the words I'm telling you
the Trump organization
as of today is under a civil lawsuit by
the Attorney General but has criminal
charges filed against it and is going to
go to trial
in in the Manhattan DA's office
criminal criminal the word criminal and
the word charges
are [ __ ] facts so you can you can
dance around about all this stupid [ __ ]
but there are criminal charges filed
against the Trump organization and Alan
weisselberg who is cooperating against
them in a plea deal where he is pled
guilty to a lesser sentence to cooperate
against the charges of the Trump
organization in the trial he is going to
be up on the stand Alan weiselberg is
going to be up on the stand in the trial
and he is going to be cooperating
against
the Trump or and if he doesn't the judge
even said in his statement I am going to
come back and I am going to lay the
hammer down on you is what I'm going to
do
so fake Gabe you can dance around in the
chat and believe all your stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] that your Facebook ivermected
and you know group tells you but there
are criminal charges filed against the
Trump organization in the state of New
York through the Manhattan DA's office
for almost the same exact fraud that
Tish James laid out today in the civil
case because there can be two things at
once there can be a civil case brought
against you and a criminal case all at
the same time it's a thing that happens
all the time these things happen a lot I
don't know if you remember O.J Simpson
but there was a criminal child of O.J
Simpson and there was a Civil Trial of
O.J Simpson which he he won the criminal
trial but he lost the Civil Trial which
really honestly maybe maybe that's the
the strategy here is to bury Trump so
fake game I really appreciate you coming
here every day and blessing us with your
stupidity so that way again we can set
the stupidity ball up on the T and knock
it out of the park I really don't
oh my God Tony just just hang out it is
almost as if there was like a search
engine I don't know Google or DuckDuckGo
whatever your preference you could just
type in these keywords right and then
read about what's
I love this I love New York attorney
general right go go to the Manhattan
DA's website dummy go to their website
the Manhattan D.A
who is a prosecutor for the state of New
York in the district of Manhattan go
there and look it up go again it's
almost like there was a way to search
for this and it's almost like you could
watch a video right of the person saying
we are now following for or we're going
forward with a lawsuit and charging them
with his crime right oh my God this fake
game yeah again it is a big game you're
you give me you give me almost like you
could just search this on me it's free
you don't even have to pay anything like
you would for the Trump fund you just
have to go online
type in your browser
New York attorney general there's no
criminal charges Trump organizations
it's very easy very simple I only listen
to my orange Mussolini Jesus and my
orange Jesus says that there's no
criminal charges good luck with that
Gabe good luck fake Gabe everyone stick
around now you do not want to miss any
episode this week I know I know it's
disappointing uh Joyce here points out
that the Lincoln project needs more
ketchup on their uh their picture here
just a smidge yeah just a little bit
cast a little bit but here's what I want
to tell you go to Tony Michaels dot live
you can get us there and let's see there
we go there that that works I want to
get out of the way of the the graphic
there Tony Michaels dot Live support
Independent Media even though we're off
YouTube a game I don't think we only get
like what two days left of this thing
two days we're trying our we're trying
our damnedest to get it lifted but I
don't think they're gonna lift it we're
just gonna have to wait wait it out and
we will come back on YouTube make sure
to follow us on on Twitter you're not
going to want to miss the bonehead of
the week the the we're still going to do
the poll we're still going to do the
bone end of the week so go follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michael's pot also stay
there for any news that we we may have
about the uh the Twitter are they excuse
me the YouTube Van update also go
download every single episode of Apple
Spotify Google and check out our brand
new merch Gabe we got some great merch
Dart Brandon merch I mean there's that
we didn't we didn't play a clip this
morning and I remember but there was a
clip of of uh dark Brandon yeah [ __ ]
dropping the mic and responding to the
little uh stunt of human trafficking
that Ron DeSantis pulled oh well
speaking of Ron DeSantis and we got some
Ron DeSantis murders too Rhonda Santos
can go [ __ ] himself go to
store.thedonymichaels.com and get your
Rhonda Santas can go [ __ ] himself in
dark Brandon merch there don't forget to
go visit the merch store at store.the
tonymichaels.com and please support
pro-democracy speech go to Deep Tony or
go to Tony Michaels dot live you can
give us a tip there you can tip once you
can tip monthly however you'd like to do
it we appreciate any kind of support you
can give us but the best support you can
give is to come back every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central right now on Twitch
Twitter and the books of face soon to be
back on YouTube soon to be back on
YouTube until tomorrow same time same
place Tony Michaels dot live twitch
Facebook Twitter soon to be YouTube
again until then Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon